so you may have seen this it's a viral
clip from a Democratic Party event that
happened to over the weekend Kamala
Harris was in the middle of speaking
when a man with a beard and a man bun
rushed onstage and grabbed her
microphone she was fine than everything
but apparently he wanted to use the
platform to talk about animal rights
there's the guy rushing up with the man
bun anyway this isn't the first time
this type of thing has happened and it's
inspired the launch of a new product
that just came out today we have a
commercial for it check it out
it happens all too often a woman picks
up a microphone and is interrupted by a
dude bro no microphone is safe from
their constant need for attention make
sure this doesn't happen to you with Roe
away Brunei is the new repellent spray
designed to keep bros away from a woman
sharing her opinions bro away uses
revolutionary pheromone technology that
bros associate with their worst possible
nightmares the 95 job expired CVD hand
lotion the cancellation of Rick and
Morty pavements reunion tour being
underwhelming an app that doesn't
disrupt anything diversity hiring
practices monogamy a trust fund drying
up Bernie Sanders retiring consequences
for actions Julian Assange is arrest
having your suggestion rejected and an
improv show and a female James Bond
throw away so you can stop worrying
about interrupting Bros and get back to
worrying about literally everything else
[Applause]